absolutely i think that the arguments
that are being made against this RF to
use a technical economic term entirely
bogus they didn't just get tarp money
they say we repaid the tarp money well
they did but you know getting alone at
the time when no one else will given to
you is a benefit even if you're letting
me pay it but there were many other
programs by the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation and the Federal
Reserve and the Secretary of Treasury to
help the financial institutions it was
very frustrating for many Americans
because it was these financial
institutions irresponsibility that had
thought about the financial crisis and
then to get out of this terrible crisis
to avoid a again Bush and butchers top
economic appointees Bernanke and Paulson
came to us in September of 2008 and said
if you don't act there'll be a total
meltdown they'll be the worst depression
ever by the way even if you didn't think
that was going to be the case and I
think it probably was when the Secretary
of Treasury and the Federal Reserve say
if you don't do this double your
meltdown there's gonna be a meltdown
it's a little bit self-fulfilling and
anyway we responded and you had to save
the economy we had to do something to
help the banks that was infuriating the
people but there was no other way around
it given the centrality of credit in our
economy so yeah I think it's entirely
reasonable now as a matter of fact that
idea that the banks have to pay for it
was in the original bill we passed now
that the bush administration's request
but the Democratic Congress is
initiative to require that the financial
institutions repay this and it doesn't
just have to be what what they got out
of the tarp they got a lot of other ways
they tell us oh but if you make us pay
this tax we will have any money to lend
first of all they're doing a lousy job
of lending now and we'll be having a
hearing couple weeks after this
interview to force them to do more if we
can but secondly the bonuses they are
giving each other far outweigh every
year the taxes so if pain is nine or ten
billion dollar zero in taxes it's going
to be a problem then what about the
hundred billion dollars in bonuses so
that's why I say it's entirely bogus
oh I didn't I don't have to use
hindsight I was against it at the time
you have to separate it out by
affordable housing we have generally met
rental housing one of the great
conservative mistakes was to kill rental
housing programs and say the way to help
low-income people with housing is to
help them buy homes frankly in many
parts of the country the housing is too
expensive following the people of my
homes I have been a critic I'm very
proud man named Larry Lindsey who was a
high economic appointee of President
Reagan and both bushes cited me is one
of the few political figures who
specifically was critical of pushing
lower income people in homeownership
yeah I think that was a terrible idea
and I said so at the time I wanted to do
more affordable rental housing I had an
argument with the Secretary of HUD mr.
Jackson Bush's Secretary of HUD and he
said he wanted to cut off section 84
people after five years that's rental
assistance I said well mr. secretary
where will they live he said we'll help
them become homeowners so yeah I think
it was a terrible mistake and I said so
at the time to push low-income people
into homeownership some can do it but
rental housing was better and it was
unfortunate ideologically opposed
you